What's that?
Amazing.
question.
Hey
Feel
Lord,
Good
morning.
Hello.
>> Good evening, friends, and welcome. My
name is Sharon. My pronouns are he,
they, and I am grateful you are here
today. I'm here that you are here with
us in person and online. Hello, friends.
Um whether this is your first time with
us or you've called this community home
for years, wherever you're coming from
today, full of faith, full of questions,
or somewhere in between, your presence
means so much to us. Um if you feel a
bit anxious about being in church
setting today, we have an accessibility
bucket available to you over at the
table to my left.
Am I van white?
Um there are noise cancelling
headphones, fidgets, coloring sheets. We
just ask that you return them to the
bucket at the service if you need them.
So, as we begin worship today, I invite
you to close your eyes and take a deep
breath in
and now out,
settling into the peace and stillness of
God. These candles are a symbol of the
mystery of the loving presence of Christ
among us. A mystery that we do not
control or contain, but rather one that
meets us in our unknowing and gently
invites us towards healing and
wholeness.
Now we exit the world of noise, hurry
and productivity.
Now we enter the realm of silence,
stillness, and simplicity.
Sacred space, a place for prayer,
worship, and adoration.
A place to behold Christ, revelation of
God, heartbeat of creation. Allow the
unforced rhythms of praise to find you,
to mend your heart. May we find
ourselves at last home.
>> Thank you, Jared.
Would you guys stand with us? We're
going to get started with our worship
tonight. And uh we have so many families
who are out traveling this week and so
we've kind of gotten to enjoy a smaller
So, I just invite you guys to sing out,
let your voices be heard. Um, but more
than anything, I just hope that you feel
settled and at peace in this room, that
this is a safe space. Your entire
presence, your whole story is welcome
and wanted. And, uh, it's such a gift
for us to share this time where we get
to um, speak out, sing out truths that
we believe are kind of our foundation
here at the table. So, please join us as
you're able to.
You're the resurrection
that we've waited for.
You buried the night
and you came with the morning.
You're the king of heaven.
The praise is yours.
The longer the quiet,
the louder the chorus. Oh,
we will sing a new song. Cuz death is
dead and gone with the winner. We will
sing a new song. Let hallelujah flow
like a river. We're coming back to life,
reaching towards the light. Your love is
like springtime.
You're the living water.
God, we thirst for you.
The dry and the billing
will flower and bloom.
You're the sun shining.
You restore my soul.
The deeper you call us. Oh, the deeper
we'll go. We will sing a new song. Cuz
death is dead and gone with the winter.
We will sing a new song. Let hallelujah
flow like a river. We're coming back to
life.
Reaching towards life. Your love is like
springtime.
Like springtime.
Come tin the soil.
Come t the soil of my soul. And like a
garden.
And like a garden I will grow.
I will grow.
Come in the soil.
comes in the soil of my soul. And like a
garden
and like a garden I will grow.
I will grow.
We will sing a new song. Cuz death is
dead and gone with the winner. We will
sing a new song that hallelu.
We're coming back to life.
Reaching towards life. We will sing a
new song cuz death is dead along with
the winner. We will sing a new song. Let
hallelu
reaching towards the light. Your love is
like springtime.
All right, we're going to dismiss our
kids to go to their kids classrooms with
their teachers. And uh your teacher is
going to meet you right over here by
this double door.
And as they go out, we're going to
transition into what we call prayers of
the people. Um, you can follow along on
the screens and the parts that we read
aloud together will be in red. And then
towards the end of our prayer, we will
leave space for you to speak out a name
or a situation that you might be
carrying into this room tonight. And uh,
hold those up before God together.
Jesus, for this city of Saxi, Texas, and
for every city and community and all who
live in them, we pray to you for the
good earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it. We
pray to you for the old and the sick,
for the widow and orphan, for the
injured and suffering. We pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized, and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those who are
struggling with mental and emotional
health, we pray to you,
Lord. We know that you hear us and that
you are with us. And so we lift these
names and situations up to you.
Those
who've lost their loved ones,
Lord, for the names in the moments that
we have spoken aloud and for those that
we have kept in our hearts. hearts. We
pray to you that they may have life and
light, healing and hope, peace, and a
deep sense of your presence. Amen.
For everyone born,
a place at the table.
for everyone born.
Clean water and bread.
A shelter, a space,
a safe place for growing
for everyone born.
A star overhead.
And God will delight when we are
creatators
of justice
and joy,
compassion
and peace.
Yes, God will delight when we are
creators
of justice,
justice and joy.
Oh,
for woman and man. For woman and man.
A place at the table.
Revising the roles.
Deciding
the share.
with wisdom and grace
dividing
the power
for genders diverse.
a system that's fair.
And God will delight when we are
creators
of justice
and joy,
compassion
and peace.
Yes, God will delight when we are
creators
of justice.
Justice and joy.
>> Justice and
for gay and for straight.
A place at the table.
A covenant shared,
a welcoming
space,
a rainbow of race,
of gender and color
for gay and for stray,
a chalice of grace.
And God will delight when we are
creators
of justice and joy,
compassion
and peace.
And God will delight when we are
creators
of justice,
justice and joy, justice and joy. Oh,
justice and joy.
>> Justice and joy.
God
is so good.
She's so good
to
me.
Goders
pray.
God
answers
prayers.
Goders
prayer.
She's so good
to
me.
She
cares for me.
She's so good
to
me.
God
is so good.
She's so good
to
me
and God will delight when we are
creatators
of justice
and joy,
compassion
and peace.
Yes, God will delight when we are
creators
of justice.
Justice and joy.
Spirit of God,
thank you for your goodness,
for your nearness,
for the way that you wrap us in loving
arms like a mother.
The way you hold us when we grieve.
The way that you believe in us
even when we're at our worst.
God, would your hand continue to guide
us
towards truth,
towards light,
towards restoration?
Would you keep creating in us wholeness
and home?
Would your spirit rest on us, on our
community, over our lives and our homes
and our relationships.
Would you breathe your spirit into us?
We love you
and tonight we confess our need and our
desire for you.
Come and stay. Spirit of God,
make us new.
Amen.
Would you guys turn to the person beside
you and say, "The peace of Christ be
with you." And then Brett will get us
started on our message.
Grace and peace. Good to be with you
all. So, so good. Y'all doing okay.
You're so quiet tonight. That's all
right. I don't mind.
My name is uh Brett and uh I'm the
pastor here. Pronouns he, him, and yeah,
a joy joy to be with you, to welcome you
into this space. And uh as always, that
includes those join us online. Love you
all lots. And uh anyone here tonight
who's new, this is your first time or
just your you know your first time in a
long time. We're really really glad that
you're you're here among us and uh yeah
grateful grateful for your presence. So
let's see we are in a a series. This is
week two um and it's a series drawing
from the work of a theologian named
David McAr. And he wrote a book titled
Holy Resilience. And so we've named the
series after that. So it's holy
resilience understanding the trauma
behind scripture and uh the kind of big
idea here is that you know so much of
what we kind of love and appreciate
about the Bible is you know the way it
can kind of swing between you know like
a lot of joy but then also like lament
and you know it's just like it's a it's
a book of deep feeling. If you've ever
read, for example, through the Psalms,
you know, it's far from maybe what you
might expect, which is maybe you might
expect just a bunch of like praise the
Lord's, you know, and then what you find
is actually like every other psalms like
a psalm of lament and grief and, you
know, kind of pathos and deep feeling
and uh sorrow, you know, the books like
Job and as we looked at last week and
some more this week, the prophets, you
know, there's going through a lot and uh
there's that's kind of stemming from
uh not just kind of pain or loss but
really what we would probably in modern
times call like traumatic suffering if
you know some of that history um there
well the people went through the the
Jewish people had uh just tremendous uh
grief through these like these
captivities and conquests you had the
Assyrian conquest very early on in like
kind of conquered the northern kingdom
of Israel and then later the Babylonians
came it was like whatund something years
720 22 was the Assyrian and 586 was the
uh the Babylonian conquest, you know. So
they come through and ransack the rest
of Judah and take kill thousands of
people, take half the intelligencia and
like the educated folks and like take
them off to Babylon and scatter them all
over uh the kind of the Babylonian
Empire. In fact, when Assyria came
through and conquered the northern
tribes, that whole community is
completely lost. like we have no trace
like Judaism did not continue from that.
In fact, there's even I think there's
maybe even documentary like the lost
tribes or something where it's just
just gone, you know, and then you had
kind of Judah and these southern nations
that kind of continued on in like
different forms and uh I mean so there's
just a whole you know history and uh
that you know that has left its mark on
the Bible. So in essence, what we love
about the scriptures is like, oh, we
just so appreciate those times where
like, you know, they're expressing that
grief and loss and such. But also some
of the things that make at least many of
us kind of wse at the Bible or kind of
like, ah, does it have to like say it
like that or like, oh geez, that seems
really messed up, you know? Um, what's
often happening there is it's a text
coming from that traumatic suffering. So
that's that's kind of where um the goal
of this series is that we would um be
kind of a more have a more
traumainformed approach to the Bible to
so that when we have those moments where
we're like you know kind of like like
what is going on here to maybe do a
little deep dive to figure out like oh
might this be one of those um you know
those texts so that so that we can
better discern uh as we often talk about
here at the table what what's good
what's true lovely noble praiseworthy in
scripture and in other times what might
be a kind of theology born from pain
that we need to kind of rework rethink
in light of the love of God in Christ.
So uh with that in mind the the title of
my message tonight is trauma and
self-lame.
Trauma and self-lame. And uh our passage
is Lamentations 1 uh verses 1-5 and then
verse 20 and verse 22. So this is the
prophet Jeremiah who's also the writer
of the book of Lamentations. And you'll
notice if you pick up on some of his
language, he's describing uh this exile.
This was the Babylonian um exile. And uh
and then he kind of towards the end he
starts moving on to some theological
implications. If I recall, I think in
our um screen you'll have certain lines
underlined. So those will be kind of the
key points to you know pay attention to.
So uh Jeremiah writes these words. He
says, "How deserted lies the city once
so full of people. How like a widow is
she who once was great among the
nations. She who was queen among the
provinces has now become a slave.
Bitterly she weeps at night. Tears are
on her cheeks. Among all her lovers,
there was no one to comfort her. All her
friends have betrayed her. They have
become her enemies. By the way, that's a
kind of metaphor there for um certain
prophets. Isaiah, Jeremiah were
criticizing the way that certain Judeian
leaders were trying to form alliances
with other nations to prevent the
Babylonian conquest. They said, "This
isn't going to work. This isn't going to
work." And they took it as a kind of um
like a like not really trusting God.
Kind of playing politics is not trusting
God. So when he's kind of referencing
here, all her friends have betrayed her.
They become her enemies. You know, this
is poetry, but it's pointing to it's
politics.
All after affliction and harsh labor,
Judah has gone into exile. She dwells
among the nations. She finds no resting
place. All who pursue her have overtaken
her in the midst of her distress. The
roads to Zion mourn, for no one comes to
her appointed festivals. All her
gateways are desolate. Her priests
groan, her young women grieve, and she
is in bitter anguish. Her foes have
become her masters. Her enemies are at
ease.
The Lord has brought her grief because
of her many sins. Her children have gone
into exile, captive before the foe. See,
Lord, how distressed I am. I am in
torment within and in my heart. I am
disturbed. For I have been most
rebellious.
Notice there how Jeremiah is very much
taking it on himself. You This isn't
just putting on the people like you all
been s, you know, he's this is like
deeply personal. It's an I and it's a
we. You know, that's that's the mindset.
I've been most rebellious. Outside the
sword bereieves. In other words, like
kills. You know, inside there's only
death. Let all their wickedness come
before you. Deal with them as you have
dealt with me because of all my sins. My
groans are many. My heart is faint.
So, I uh I met with a woman named
Sarah's. Not her real name, but uh we'll
roll with that. and she's not an
attendee of the table, but there might
be some folks who maybe through certain
circumstances know her. So, um I'll keep
her kind of identity hidden. But I met
her um for the first time in I think it
was Rowlette, maybe it was years ago,
four fourish years ago, kind of another
iteration of the table. And uh her
therapist had said she needed to like do
a search for like a gay affirming
pastor, someone to give a little bit
different perspective. And so uh you
know I didn't like know her but just
reached out via her website and uh asked
if I would you know could get coffee and
so uh you know we did we met there and
uh you know outwardly was interesting
like she was in a lot of ways sort of a
picture of success like great job
um had uh nice car nice home in the
suburbs you know like this little
suburban life um but kind of in inwardly
though inside like she was really I mean
I would I would I don't think this
exaggeration I would say she was like
tormented uh it was incredibly intense
what she was going through severely
depressed extremely anxious in danger of
losing that precious job I remember uh
when I met with her the ways the way her
kind of eyes like almost kept darting
around the coffee shop um it's like she
was kind of on alert I don't know she
just you know you could tell that
nervous system was like it was up you
know and maybe she was I think she was
probably also nervous about meeting with
with me and opening up, you know, but uh
and yet she pushed through, you know,
there she was and I guess you desperate
times, desperate measures and you know,
all that. So, she started to open up her
her story poured out and uh honestly,
you know, for someone like in my
position, the story itself wasn't like,
you know, wildly unique for the table.
Never heard another story like it. you
know, it's uh she was a gay woman born
into a conservative family, born to
cons, you know, conservative church from
like her earliest days, you know, all
the way through. And uh and she yeah,
faithfully attended church for most of
her life. But um I would say what was
unique was like the level the degree to
which it was impacting her. I think some
of this was just her own sensitivity.
She's just one of those people that
just, you know, attuned and and uh fe
felt feelings, you know, deeply and uh
and it was just like it was just hitting
her so um hard. And I think, you know,
some people can even attend church for a
long time, but it's kind of like one in
year out the other, you know, it's or if
they like kind of something in them
disagrees, they're just kind of like,
oh, whatever. You know, they just don't
take like they don't it doesn't hit
them, you know? She was not that person.
It hit her, you know, I mean the words
of the pastor or the what like it was
just like boom. And so she just taken
all of these things to heart. And I
mean, in essence, she she really
genuinely
believed she was a a terrible wretch for
being gay. And she kept saying even, you
know, over and over again to me, like, I
know, I know it's wrong. I know it is. I
I know it's evil. I know what the Bible
says. I know, you know, I'm I'm a
sinner. She even told me a little story.
She said, "For a while, I was in a
relationship with a woman and then it
didn't work out." And my her mother had
told her, "Well, that's because, you
know, it's not a God-honoring
relationship. Like, it'll never work
out." And and she like really owned
that. Like, it wasn't just like, "Can
you believe what my mom said?" Like,
"No, no, no." It was like, "My mom's
right. She's she's absolutely, you know,
right. And uh she's just, you know,
taking it all on. It's my fault. It's my
fault." And uh I kind of sensed during
that coffee visit like it I did I did
speak words, you know, I did say some
things to try to kind of give some
guidance, but I could kind of tell like
this just wasn't this wasn't the time
for a lot of words, you know, for like
what? No, no, no. That's that's not
right. you know, like um I could tell it
was kind of more of a a listening
moment, you know, kind of just being a I
don't know, a certain hopefully loving,
accepting, you know, presence there. Uh
because like Jeremiah in this passage
from Lamentations, what was so clear was
the pain behind her words. I mean it was
really it was the pain of someone who
imagines themselves
to be divinely judged.
And you can hear
that kind of pain in the passage we just
read.
Correct? And uh and and again as we you
know kind of named right that that kind
of honesty that kind of raw honesty is a
part of part of the allure of the Bible.
It's going to be very raw kind of like
poetry just going to put it out there
you know. Um, but at the same time,
it's also that same type of theology,
some of that underlined stuff that we
were reading, you know, that's kind of
like
like I don't know what, you know, when
when people say, I read the Bible, but
parts of it I really really struggled
with, it's often lines like that. Uh,
this kind of image of a very, you know,
judgmental, harsh um harsh God. And I
know at least even speaking for myself
and my own kind of deconstruction
journey and wrestling with theology and
what kind of a Christian I would be and
such. It was passages like that that
drove me absolutely
you know bananas.
um this this idea that that uh for their
many sins for their lack of holiness
that ah Assyria or Babylon whoever this
was the you know the very hand of the
Lord bringing judgment upon them uh but
as we touched on last week it's not just
the uh book of lamentations or something
here's a few other examples um and again
notice these prophetic books these are
written you know post exile the
Babylonian exile Um, so here's Ezra
9:6-7. I'm too ashamed and disgraced, my
God, to lift up my face to you. Because
our sins are higher than our heads and
our guilt has reached to the heavens.
From the days of our ancestors until
now, our guilt has been great. Because
of our sins, we and our kings and our
priests have been subjected to the sword
in captivity. Here's Nehemiah 1 6-7. I
confess the sins we Israelites,
including myself and my father's family,
have committed against you. We have
acted very wickedly toward you. We have
not obeyed the commands, the decrees,
and the laws you gave your servant
Moses. Hosea 14:1, "Return, Israel, to
the Lord your God. Your sins have been
your downfall." Micah 7:9, "Because I
have sinned against him, I will bear the
Lord's wrath." Zechariah 1:6, "They
repented and said,"The Lord Almighty has
done to us what our ways and practices
deserve, just as he determined to do."
So, my point in reading all those isn't
just to overwhelm you with like, "Oh my
gosh, this is like awful." Um, but to
show you kind of this matter, you know,
that like this is kind of all peppered
all through um scripture, but mostly the
the Hebrew Bible, the Old Testament. So
what we touched on last week was that
that I think a lot of these writings
this is um very possibly kind of coming
from this traumatic place that that this
idea of the judgment of God and kind of
ascribing it to you know God is is a
kind of trauma response. Um in other
words rather than saying like this is
how I would say something like this. I
think we live in a fallen crazy world
where terrible things happen that yes,
you could say in some sense God allows
um and will at the end of all things
reheal and restore and set right, but
for now there's a kind of allowance.
That's different than God divinely
actively
wills it, desires it, uses it, wants it
to like yes, this is how it must be as
you know a kind of pay payback. So
that's kind of what we covered last
week. But the next move I think after
that is for like a traumatized person
who believes this like I'm divinely
judged is to ask and why, right? Why do
I think God willed that? And they would
say, you know, why did God bring this
judgment upon me or my family or, you
know, whatever. Ah, it's because of my
sins, my shortcomings, my failure to
live a good and holy life.
Again, you see this all through kind of
scattered throughout the scriptures.
Uh, noticeably though, not so much in
Jesus, which is interesting. Even
there's that you might remember that
little moment where uh there's a man was
he's either lame or blind or something
and then the disciples are like uh who
sinned this man or his parents that he
was born blind you know it's like it's
kind of this classic like well some
they've got to deserve it somehow you
know and what does Jesus say like oh
neither this man nor his parents were
sinners but it was actually that God's
glory might be revealed then he heals
them you know it's so it's like Jesus is
on a little different track here but
nonetheless um this is a kind of theme
you see in in scripture so the way David
Carr kind of summarizes This is he says
this prophetic blame of Israel for
Assyrian oppression offered a sense of
control amidst an overwhelming
experience. As Kai Ericson has observed,
groups that are traumatized often feel
as if their world has suddenly proven to
be dominated by randomness and chaotic
violence.
They come to feel that something awful
is bound to happen. In response, trauma
survivors often seek some reason for
their trauma in their own behavior. They
escape the sense of a terrorizing world
by attributing at least part of their
trauma to behavior that they can
control.
People who suffer regain a sense of
power by drawing some kind of lesson
from their experience to feel that they
could have avoided suffering by acting
otherwise. that can be more bearable
than facing the reality of total
helplessness.
Such self-lame offered Israel a way to
see itself as empowered in an otherwise
helpless situation.
I think that's a absolutely
fascinating
angle uh and insight into how to
understand these texts and kind of it
honestly helped me clarify like not only
perhaps where these biblical writers
were coming from, right? the way their
own backgrounds are kind of informing
their image of God and the way they're
like doing theology and processing all
this. Uh, but it it also
well it gave me insight into um the
conversations I've had with people like
Sarah, the woman I mentioned earlier,
kind of down through the years. I mean,
if I had a dollar for every time someone
said something to the effect of, "Well,
this is what I get for fill in the
blank, you know, for not turning to God
sooner in my life. This is what I get
for staying in that abusive situation.
You know, this is what I get for being
gay. This is what I get for leaving the
church. This is God's judgment of me."
If I had a dollar for every time someone
said something like that, I'd be a much
richer church planter. you know,
like in fact, even just speaking um
speaking kind of even for myself and
this isn't so much from like a trauma,
but I'll just say I think kind of any of
us can start to slip into this when we
start going through hard times and you
just it's like it has explanatory power
and as Car points out it kind of gives
you a certain sense of agency uh because
you can change the behavior you know and
uh example of this in my own life is
that many of you know kind of throughout
like 2024 for first half or so of like
2025, it was just very difficult for us
as a church. We had a number of like key
beloved members move away. Uh we had
some even some kind of relational pain
and and some folks that had some kind of
relational crisis in the community. Uh
we had um what else? I wrote various
things down. Um oh the number of deaths
of like beloved members in in the
community. So, we're going through all
this and
it was just so painful. It was just very
hard time. And I remember a conversation
I had with uh my wife Maggie and her
sister-in-law, our worship leader,
Mindy. We're like sitting around the
table and we're just like processing and
talking and we mentioned that these like
kind of intrusive like thoughts had just
started to like sort of come into our
minds and it was something along the
lines of like ah
this is it.
God's judgment upon us.
See the table as a queer church. Ah it's
not really God-honoring. It's going to
fail.
You know, I'm not saying that's true.
I'm saying that was like the the
thoughts that just start like kind of
finding their way, you know, into the
back of your your mind. And
there is something psychologically
weirdly tempting about this. So why why
do we do this though? Uh especially if
we've been through some sort of
traumatic uh experience, why are we more
likely to do I think this is where Car's
insight is helpful that sometimes just
kind of sitting with the utter
randomness and chaos of the world, you
know, it's almost just too much for us
to bear. And so in a kind of surprising
twist, we actually empower ourselves
through blaming ourselves.
Isn't that strange? We we empower by
blaming.
It gives us a sense of agency again,
right? Because we say, "Ah, there's
something I could do different."
See how that kind of puts us back to the
center of like I'm in control here. You
know,
there there's something we could do
different. We could we could repent. We
could turn our life around. We could
pursue holiness, you know, and then
we'll avoid these traumatic experiences
forever. I think that's some of those
passages from scripture we read earlier.
I think that's the logic. We've just
been through absolute hell and it can't
be that like somehow sometimes you just
go through terrible things and you just
got to trust God to bring you through
and you don't know why. That's almost
too pain. It's almost more kind of uh
not helpful, but it's at least in the
short run. We could say it's adaptive
and it'll get you through the day to
say, "Ah, okay. No, it's because I
messed up. it's because I'm like a bad
crappy person and like don't worry I'm
going to change it and I'm going to get
this back on track you know and that
becomes this this kind of uh story that
we tell ourselves. Now we've been
discussing the kind of you know
religious flavor of this but of course
for you know traumatized people do this
all the time even without like bringing
God into it. Uh it's things like, you
know, oh, if only I hadn't been out that
late. You know, I shouldn't have been
out that late. I if only I hadn't been
in that part of town. If only I hadn't
married them. I knew it. I knew I should
not have married them. It's all my
fault. You know, the abuse, the terror,
it's ah, it's my fault. There's
something I could have done.
And again, psychologically, it kind of
helps us like get through the
experience.
But, uh, the question is what's waiting
for us on kind of the backside
of this?
Uh, I think we'll call this the shadow
side of self-lame. Again, in the short
run, helps you get through the day,
helps you survive, you know, but in the
long run, what what happens here? Um, a
few things for this shadow side. First,
we'll call it shame migration.
This is how a kind of um behavioral
self-lame, you know, I did something
wrong. I really failed, you know,
becomes um kind of a character
self-lame. You know, it's like you tell
yourself that story long enough and all
of a sudden I am something wrong. You
know, I'm just a bad stupid person. I'm
the type of person that this just
happens to. I attract it. I deserve it.
I you know and you can see where it's
like oh no this is really heaping it on
the shame. Uh another is hypervigilance
and exhaustion
right if the logic is I can prevent this
I can prevent this through my own
efforts and vigilance and awareness and
my own good behavior. I will I will
always be on the watch.
I will always be on the alert. You're
like for how long? for my whole life.
It's like, okay, that'll work for about
a week and then you're going to be
utterly. Your nervous system is just
like, well, we've been at level 10 for a
year now. How's this going? You know, it
it's uh becomes it's tough to keep up.
We'll put it that way. Tough to keep up
for months, maybe even years. Uh,
another would be stuck grief
where
uh we in essence we kind of see almost
like um well maybe we we might struggle
to grieve a thing that we think we've
caused,
right? If it didn't just happen to me,
but it's like it happened because of me.
And then it's not a thing to grieve.
It's a thing to fix, you know, instead
of a a situation that's kind of a little
bit distant for me and I need to just
grieve the loss, grieve the feeling, you
know, um work through it in that way. Um
finally, we have abusive and dangerous
images of God. And I would say there
even for maybe someone who's like I
don't believe in God or something even
just well then substitute the view of
reality itself for God. You don't want
to use the word God. Fine. reality
capital R, you know, just we start to
imagine in essence kind of um the the
nature of reality itself or God as
something like kind of bleak and dark
and dangerous and that gets us wonky,
you know, that we start bargaining and
negotiating and appeasing or kind of
lashing out in anger and rage. Um it it
just becomes problematic. And just to be
clear again, these aren't just things
that like happened to Israel long long
ago, you know, this is relevant to us
today. I mean, here and now for millions
of Christians all over the world. And uh
and not just Christians, all sorts of
religious people. And as I said, not
even just religious people, like just
people in general. Um we struggle with
with these with these things. Um, so how
do we how do we move forward? Um, we'll
get more into this next week, but I want
to at least touch on uh this a little
bit now. Um, first we'll call it step
one. I think we want to honor the coping
strategy, you know. So, in other words,
rather not just critiquing it or being
like it could almost be more self-lame.
It's like self-lame for my self-lame,
you know, like I've been terrible. You
went every point of this sermon is like
me me. I'm just the worst person. I've
just for years now I've been this is not
what we need. Um honor the coping
strategy like hey no no no it got you
here. It got you survived. You made it.
Congratulations. This is throw a little
party like here you are. Um it just
might not be the thing to take you
forward.
Just might not be the thing to to move
you um towards healing.
So, you survived and that's, you know,
that's a win.
But step two, I would say we need a new
story. And for this, I would say go to
therapy, go to church, whatever it
takes, and and start to take in a new
story, right? not a self-blame story,
but rather one of self-acceptance
and even love, compassion towards
yourself. That's very for some some of
us um we're we're incredibly harsh on
ourselves, just so demanding, difficult.
And that ties in again with that
self-lame. There's something about
becoming gentle, learning this kind of
new new heart posture towards us and
thus even of others.
So when I left that meeting with uh with
Sarah so many years ago, I honestly
thought like
yikes, this is bad. like I I was just I
was worried she would just sink like
down down like it uh I remember I was
even more discouraged when she said
she'd already read Matthew Vine's book
God and the Gay Christian and she's like
I just know what's wrong you know I was
kind oh gosh like she's just you there's
just this kind of sinking down
but
she ended up finding like a church
closer to her home uh a small group and
even beyond that small group like this a
group of Christian friends and she kept
she was going to therapy. She continued
doing that. uh she did start to engage
some engage some new theology and like
kind of started to break through the the
the darkness a little bit and like over
about two years
honestly she just it was very slow like
it just she just slowly like blossomed
and I mean I honestly I could not I just
could not believe it. It was like almost
like all of that self-lame and you know
all these like violent angry images of
God just kind of like started to somehow
melt away.
And in fact the last time I saw her I
remember at first I hardly recognized
her. You know why? Because she was
smiling. I realized up to that point she
was so depressed. I had never seen her
smile. And then she's like, "Hey Brett."
And I was like, "Oh my gosh." I just
could not could not believe this. you
know, and
there's something I I think well when I
just saw that transformation
like by God's grace, I just like thought
to myself, "Oh my god, if that can
happen for Sarah, like there is hope for
every person sitting here tonight uh and
engaging us online. I don't want to
forget y'all either, but like there's
just there's hope for for all of us to
um engage this and move forward." And
really when I see all of you, like what
I really do see are a people who are
learning to heal, learning to move
forward, learning to move kind of beyond
these reflexive, you know, reactive kind
of coping strategies. And to be clear, I
don't just mean LGBTQ folks tonight. Uh
I mean all of us, like we're all having
to unlearn and relearn some new
theology. We're we're having to learn
God is for you, right? not against you.
You're learning that yes, the world is a
crazy and at times awful place, but you
have people who love you and God is on
your side. God is for you, not against
you. God's calling us and all things to
toward healing and hope and restoration
and and really greater greater is the
spirit of love in you than whatever
awful evil is at times running a muck in
this world. And so I I think I want to
encourage us like church like let's just
continue let's continue on this journey
towards healing for the rest of our
lives. and may it allow us to read the
scriptures and really the book of our
own lives uh with greater compassion.
In the name of the father, the son and
the holy spirit. Amen.
So on the night before his death, Jesus
took bread. He gave thanks. He broke it
and he said, "This is my body given for
you." And after supper, he took the cup
and he said, "This is my blood poured
out for you. Whenever you share this,
remember me." And so tonight, we
proclaim the mystery of faith. Christ
has died. Christ is risen. And Christ
will come again.
So, the way we'll go about taking
communion tonight is we'll just kind of
go row by row starting with row number
two and uh forming a line right here in
the middle. We just stall out
immediately. It's like, well, the first
row is not going. So, right here, we'll
start in the middle and we'll just kind
of work our way back. So, when one row
is done, the next can, you know, jump
into the line. Um, everyone's welcome to
participate. We practice what's called
an open table. So, if you're here
tonight, you want to participate, feel
free to do that. Uh at the same time, if
you'd rather not, uh that's that's okay.
Okay, too. There's no pressure. Just
know the red is wine and the white is
grape juice. And finally, you can just
partake whenever and however you'd like.
Uh some folks take immediately, some
like to come and kneel at the front. Uh
just however you want to partake of the
elements. You can go ahead and do that
on your own. So, this is the table, not
of the church, but of the Lord, and it's
made ready for those who love him and
for those who want to love him more. So
come you who have much faith and you who
have little. You who have been here
often and you who have not been here
long. You who have tried to follow and
you who have failed. Come. Come because
it's the Lord Jesus himself who invites
you. And it's his will that those who
want to meet him should meet him here.
Come to the table.
What did you do?
That's right.
Smooth.
Gracious God,
we thank you for this holy mystery.
We thank you for meeting us here,
for feeding us with love.
We ask that you send us out renewed by
your spirit to give ourselves to others.
Amen.
>> 2 Corinthians 5:16.
So from now on we regard no one from a
worldly point of view. Though we once
regarded Christ in this way, we do so no
longer. Therefore, if anyone is in
Christ, he is a new creation. The old
has gone, the new has come.
All this is from God who reconciled us
to himself through Christ and gave us
the ministry of reconciliation.
That God was reconciling the world to
himself in Christ, not counting men's
sins against them. And he has committed
to us the message of reconciliation.
Would you stand with me and sing these
words as we close?
Would
you take Lord and receive my liberty,
my memory,
my understanding
and my will. soul that I call my own.
Give
me
only
your loving grace.
Your love and grace,
that is enough.
That is enough
for
me.
You have given all to me. To you, Lord,
I return
it.
Everything
belongs to you. Do with it what you
will.
Give
me
your loving grace.
Your loving grace.
That is enough.
That is enough
for
me.
For
Thank you so much for joining us
tonight.
If you're interested in joining a small
group, attending a table event,
supporting the table financially, or if
you're new and you'd be willing to fill
out a visitor card so we have a record
of your visit, you can take any of those
steps by scanning the QR code and
filling out the appropriate link or by
filling out a physical card and placing
it into the box on the credenza by the
doors you entered through.
I'd like to invite you to stand with me.
We already are. Thank you. Um,
and let me send you into this week with
this blessing. You can hold out your
hands in a posture to receive or just
open your heart to these words.
You are a child of God.
You are a child of God. This is true on
your best day and it's true on your
worst day.
So as you go into your week ahead with
the yetto beet determined highs and lows
and everything in between, go filled
with the assurance that you are loved.
You are worthy and you are accepted just
as you are.
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
that desire to extend these same gifts
of grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come in contact with. Be
blessed and we'll see you next Sunday.
Give
me
only
your loving grace.
>> Your loving grace.
>> That is enough.
That is enough
for
me.
For